- [Narrator] This
animation is brought to you
by the Smart Imagebase,
a subscription website
where you can download
thousands of medical images and videos
to use in lectures,
courses, presentations,
professional training and more.
For more information,
click on the link in the description.
Immunization is the process
of becoming immune to
or protected against a disease,
usually by receiving a vaccine.
Vaccines stimulate your immune system
to protect you from certain diseases
so you won't get sick or get an infection.
Normally, the organs and
cells of your immune system
defend your body from harmful germs
such as bacteria and viruses.
Immune cells are constantly
circulating through your body.
They monitor certain substances
on the surfaces of cells called antigens.
Healthy cells have different antigens
than diseased body cells
or foreign invaders in the body.
Immune cells usually ignore
the antigens on healthy cells.
But when immune cells come
across antigens on germs,
they destroy the germ.
Afterward, the immune cell
displays the germ's antigen
on its surface.
This activates other types of immune cells
to help get rid of the infection.
For example, some activated immune cells
recognize the antigen
on infected body cells
and then destroy them.
Other activated immune
cells, called plasma cells,
make molecules called antibodies.
These antibodies travel through your body
and lock on only to germs that
have its specific antigen.
This marks the germ for destruction.
Then, other immune cells attack the germs
that have these antibodies.
Once the infection is gone,
some of the immune cells that
were exposed to the antigen
become memory immune cells.
In the future, if the same type of germ
infects your body again,
the memory immune cells
will be ready to destroy it
so you don't get sick.
This is called natural immunity.
In many cases, it will
last your whole lifetime.
The problem with getting natural immunity
from having the disease itself
is that some naturally-acquired infections
can cause serious complications
or may even be deadly.
For example, polio can result
in permanent paralysis or death.
Measles can cause swelling of the brain,
resulting in permanent
brain damage or death,
especially in children under age five.
And whooping cough,
also known as pertussis,
can cause complications such as pneumonia,
slowed or stopped breathing and death,
especially in babies
under one year of age.
While symptoms may not
be severe in all people,
it's not possible to know
who will be affected enough
to become very ill or even die.
Vaccines can protect you
from getting these diseases
and their harmful symptoms.
Vaccines often contain a small amount
of weakened or killed germs,
but some contain genetic material
such as RNA or DNA
that provide instructions
for your body's own cells
to make the germ's antigen.
Usually, you receive a vaccine as a shot.
Inside your body, the germ
particles in the vaccine
teach your immune cells
to attack these germs.
This process doesn't make you sick
but it does cause your
body to make memory cells
and the antibodies for those germs.
As a result, if that germ
infects your body later in life,
your immune system is ready
to fight the infection
so that you don't get sick.
The main types of vaccines include
live attenuated vaccines,
inactivated vaccines, toxoid vaccines,
subunit and conjugate vaccines,
mRNA vaccines, and viral vector vaccines.
Live attenuated vaccines use
alive but weakened germs.
They're most like a natural infection
and provide a strong disease immunity.
Examples are the measles, mumps, rubella,
chicken pox and flu nasal spray vaccines.
Inactivated vaccines use
inactive or killed germs.
You may need several doses
or booster shots over time.
Examples are the hepatitis A, flu, polio,
and rabies vaccines.
Toxoid vaccines protect
against harmful substances
made by germs called toxins.
They use weakened versions
of the toxins called toxoids.
You may need booster shots
to maintain protection against diseases.
Examples are the diptheria
and tetanus parts
of the DTaP vaccine.
Subunit and conjugate vaccines
use only a specific part of a germ.
They provide strong immunity
to that key part of the germ.
These vaccines may also
require booster shots.
Examples are the pertussis
part of the DTaP vaccine
and the hepatitis B vaccine.
Instead of using germs or toxins,
mRNA vaccines contain
a special type of RNA
called messenger RNA, or mRNA.
mRNA instructs your cells
to make the germ's antigen,
which triggers an immune response.
These vaccines do not carry live virus
and do not change your DNA.
Examples are certain COVID-19 vaccines.
Viral vector vaccines may
use either DNA or mRNA
to provide cells with instructions
to make a germ's antigen.
The genetic material is wrapped
in a different safe virus
to take the instructions into your cells.
These vaccines do not change your DNA.
Examples are certain COVID-19 vaccines.
It's important to know that vaccines
not only protect you but
your community as well.
Many diseases that vaccines prevent
are spread from person to person.
When only a few people in
your community are vaccinated,
the risk of a disease outbreak is high.
But if most people are vaccinated,
it's much less likely
for a disease to spread.
This is called community or herd immunity.
Herd immunity is especially important
to protect people who can't be vaccinated.
This includes people with
weakened immune systems,
serious allergies or
other health conditions.
Vaccines protect you, your
family, and your community
from diseases that can be
dangerous or even deadly.
To find out more about vaccines,
talk to your healthcare provider.